und jetzt kommen wir schon zum nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt
ja es war eine einigung im letzten
moment kann man sagen nämlich kurz vor
der bundestagswahl kam der
rechtsanspruch zur ganztagsbetreuung für
grundschulkinder noch durch zuvor hatten
bund und länder heftig und lange über
die finanzierung gestritten aber im
september hat der vermittlungsausschuss
gerade noch rechtzeitig ein kompromiss
erzielt dass bundestag und bundesrat
zustimmen konnten sonst wäre das ganze
verfallen und hätte es von vorne
diskutiert werden müssen wer bezahlt das
alles der große streitpunkt war das in
der verhandlung einige länder fanden
dass der bund zu wählen dazu geben
wollte man einigte sich darauf dass der
boden zunächst mit 3,5 milliarden
investitionskosten sich beteiligt es
wird nun in dem hier vorliegenden
gesetzentwurf darum gehen dass die
laufzeit ist investitionsprogramm für
den beschleunigten ausbau der
ganztagsbetreuung für grundschulkinder
um ein jahr zu verlängern
[Musik]
und es gibt übrigens auch noch einen
gesetzentwurf der cdu csu fraktion der
hiermit beraten worauf der deckt sich in
vielen punkten mit dem der ampel
koalition
die laufzeit des programms sagt die cdu
csu um ist aber nicht nur verlängert
werden
auch die fristen für die entsprechenden
mittel sollen angepasst werden also das
werden wir noch detailliert in der
aussprache führen jetzt eine erste rede
einer neuen ministerin nämlich von einem
spiegel der neuen
bundesfamilienministerin
sie war ja vorher schon landesministerin
in rheinland pfalz
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte abgeordnete sehr geehrte zu
hörende eines der beliebtesten gedichte
der deutschen heißt stufen der titel ist
nicht so bekannt aber den satz jedem
anfang wohnt ein zauber inne den kennen
sehr viele und er passt zu diesem tag in
verschiedener hinsicht
politisch weil die neue erste
ampelkoalition auf bundesebene ihre
arbeit aufgenommen hat und zeigt sie
will etwas bewegen und so hoffe ich sie
wird auch viel bewegen aber auch
aber auch für mich persönlich passt der
satz denn dies ist meine erste rede als
bundesfamilienministerin
in diesem hohen hause und das gleich zu
einem thema das mir auch wirklich sehr
am herzen liegt es geht um eine gute
zuverlässige kinderbetreuung die kinder
und familien stärkt dafür hat die letzte
bundesregierung mit dem rechtsanspruch
auf ganztagsbetreuung für
grundschulkinder die weichen gestellt
und jetzt ist der zug aus dem bahnhof
und das liegt in den kommenden jahren
noch eine lange strecke vor uns und
deshalb sorgen wir heute dafür dass
unser ganztagszug richtig ins rollen
kommt ich möchte mich zunächst einmal
ganz herzlich bedanken bei den
fraktionen und dort insbesondere bei den
bericht erstatte rinnen und
berichterstattern dass sie diesen
gesetzentwurf eingebracht haben er ist
wahrlich ein entwurf aus der mitte des
parlaments
wir verlängern mit diesem gesetzentwurf
die fristen für die erste tranche der
investitionsmittel für den ausbau von
ganztagsschulen die länder erhalten
damit ein jahr mehr zeit um die
insgesamt 750 millionen euro abzurufen
die der bund seit ende 2020 bereit
stellt das fordern auch der bundesrat
und die cdu/csu-fraktion in ihren
jeweiligen gesetzentwürfen aber wir
gehen darüber noch hinaus indem wir die
förderstruktur vereinfachen wir schlagen
die zusätzlichen bonus mittel in höhe
von nochmals 750 millionen euro den
basis mittel im ganztags hilfe gesetzt
zu somit sind zukünftig
2,75 milliarden euro im topf und damit
setzen wir erstens eine forderung des
koalitionsvertrages um zweitens kommen
wir damit den ländern entgegen sie
benötigen mit blick auf die besonderen
herausforderungen der korona pandemie
des baustoffs und des fachkräftemangels
einfach mehr zeit um die
investitionsmittel abzurufen
und drittens und auch dass es wichtig
wir bauen mit dem gesetz bürokratie ab
und wir schaffen mehr planungssicherheit
für länder und kommunen was die
bundesmittel für den ganztags ausbau
angeht meine damen und herren was wir
heute der abstimmung vorlegen ist der
nächste schritt auf dem weg zu einer
verlässlichen guten ganztagsbetreuung in
unserem land dass wir nur wenige tage
nach der regierungsbildung schon diesen
schritt gehen das freut mich aber ich
sage auch
ich sage auch dass es heute nur der
anfang gemeinsam mit meinem haus und
ihnen liebe abgeordnete will ich in den
kommenden jahren dafür arbeiten dass wir
unseren koalitionsvertrag umsetzen wir
wollen das gute kita gesetz
fortentwickeln und bis ende der
legislatur in ein qualitäts entwicklungs
gesetz überführen wir wollen die kinder
grundsicherung auf den weg bringen
wir wollen den ausbau der
ganztagsangebote für grundschulkinder im
gemeinsam mit den ländern voranbringen
und dabei geht es nicht nur um
zusätzliche horträume ich weiß gebäude
sind wichtig es heißt nicht umsonst der
raum ist der dritte pädagoge
es geht auch um qualität es geht um
förder und freizeitangebote die kinder
wie pädagoginnen wie eltern überzeugen
es geht um lern und lebensort an dem
sich unsere kinder wohlfühlen und die
von den kindern her gedacht und
konzipiert sind und das
und das geht nicht ohne personal und
deshalb werden wir eine gesamtstrategie
auf den weg bringen um mehr fachkräfte
zu gewinnen und im beruf zu halten und
noch einiges mehr
das alles kann der bund nicht alleine
leisten das ist eine gesamtstaatliche
aufgabe für die es eine gemeinsame
kraftanstrengung braucht das gute ist
wir wissen wofür wir es tun für gute
faire bildungschancen für alle kinder
und für eine gute vereinbarkeit auf die
sich eltern verlassen können damit sie
ihre kinder auf ihrem weg in unsere
gesellschaft gut begleiten können
schritt für schritt und stufe für stufe
und lassen sie mich abschließend
ausdrücklich für diese vielen schritte
und stufen denjenigen danken die gerade
in einer corona pandemie tagtäglich in
den schulen dafür sorgen und zwar
angefangen bei den hausmeistern über die
reinigungskräfte über die lehrkräfte die
schulsozialarbeit bis zu den
schulleitung unter verwaltung die dafür
sorgen dass unsere kinder tagtäglich gut
lernen gut aufwachsen können und sie mit
diesem bildungsangebot ein anker der
stabilität und geborgenheit in dieser
schwierigen corona pandemie haben
alle spiegel die neue
bundesfamilienministerin kennt das
erringen und den ausbau der ausbau der
ganztagsbetreuung für grundschulkinder
ausländer und aus jetzt bundes sich denn
sie war bis mai 2021 ministerin für
familie frauen und jugend integration in
rheinland pfalz und seit der
landtagswahl dann für klimaschutz und
umwelt zuständig und seit letzten
mittwoch hier die bundesministerin in
der aussprache folgt ihr jetzt dorothee
bär für die cdu/csu-fraktion
ich ganz herzlich in beiden neuen
ministerinnen jetzt auch gleich in der
debatte sprechen werten gratulieren zum
neuen amt liebe frau spiegel liebevoll
stark watzinger herzlichen glückwunsch
alles gute ich freue mich auf die
zusammenarbeit mit ihnen und es wird
sicherlich in der sache an der einen
oder anderen stelle auch hart zugehen in
den nächsten jahren aber immer
angemessen im ton heute ist es ein thema
wo wir noch nicht streiten müssen weil
die dankenswerterweise den antrag von
uns abgeschrieben
wir haben gemeinsam am ende der letzten
legislaturperiode
beschlossen die nachmittagsbetreuung für
grundschulkinder auszubauen und ab 2026
kommt der rechtsanspruch dass es ein
wirklicher meilenstein für familie und
beruf und auch ein maßgeblicher beitrag
für mehr bildungsgerechtigkeit in
unserem land es ist uns wichtig weil es
auch eine echte entlastung ist für den
kern unserer gesellschaft für die mütter
und väter in unserem land die eben jeden
tag unser land am laufen halten und es
ermöglicht und das ist unserer fraktion
ganz besonders wichtig eben auch echte
wahlfreiheit
wir haben zugesagt dass die notwendigen
voraussetzungen geschaffen werden dass
mittel bereitgestellt werden und mit dem
gesetzentwurf der regierungskoalition
jetzt zur änderung des ganztags
finanzierungsgesetzes und des ganztags
finanzhilfe gesetzes wird jetzt endlich
sack endlich weiß jetzt wirklich kurz
vor schluss am jahresende die frist für
die kommunen zum abruf der mittel aus
dem ganztags ausbau vor verlängert das
begrüßen wir ausdrücklich
wir begrüßen ist weil wir wirklich etwas
auch schaffen nicht nur für die familien
auf der einen seite sondern weil wir
auch als fraktion für die kommunen auf
der anderen seite dafür sorgen dass wir
planungssicherheit für unsere kommunen
in diesem land bekommen
planungssicherheit dass der ausbau der
nachmittagsbetreuung plätze auch
weitergehen kann ein ganz ganz wichtiges
signal und liebe frau ministerin
spiegels grad selber in ihrer rede
gesagt gut und zuverlässig das
unterstütze ich ausdrücklich und sag
ihnen aber auch an dieser stelle das
hätten sie alles schon viel früher haben
können warum haben sie denn unseren
antrag abgelehnt am 11 november mit
genau dem gleichen inhalt warum
abgelehnt obwohl er eins zu eins der
gleiche inhalt es warum unser
gesetzentwurf vom 18 november hätten sie
auch schon haben können jetzt haben eine
woche vor weihnachten und die kommunen
mein kollege wird ja kein doch dazu
sprechen von der kommunalpolitischen
seite hat natürlich die ganzen
beschwerden bekommen der
kommunalpolitiker die sich gefragt haben
wie uns so verlässlich ist diese neue
regierung für die kommunen und das
bedauere ich sehr der bundesrat hat sie
auch überholt ihre eigenen regierten
länder haben nicht an sie geglaubt
und haben deswegen auch noch mal in der
sitzung am 26 november beschlossen einen
eigenen gesetzentwurf einzubringen
einziger gegenstände fristverlängerung
weil es vertrauen eben ihre eigenen
ländern sie auch nicht gegeben es muss
ihnen doch zu denken geben an dieser
stelle
jetzt können wir eben in dem
gesetzentwurf neben der unzweifelhaft
notwendigen fristverlängerung auch die
zusammenlegung der basis und bonus
mittel dass es eine gute entscheidung
auch das hätten wir gerne schon von
anfang an in der vorherigen regierung
beschlossen nur wer hat es abgelehnt wer
hat es abgelehnt der damalige
bundesfinanzminister ich glaube
mittlerweile ist der bundeskanzler also
er hat auf jeden fall abgelehnt hätten
auch schon länger haben können ist ja
gut dass jetzt die erfreuliche 130 da
ist aber es ist schade
also mir tut es leid weil es viel
vertrauen in die kommunen ohne not
zerstört wurde in mir tut es leid dass
ohne not auch viel vertrauen bei den
familien verloren gegangen wurde ich
kann ihnen nur anbieten dass wir immer
die familien und die kinder in den
mittelpunkt unseres handelns stellen und
ich wünsche mir einfach weil das ja
heute schon mehrfach angesprochen wurde
dass die neue koalition behauptet dass
die macht des besseren argument es zählt
dass sie auch auf eine so gute
oppositionskurs partei wie die cdu und
die csu auf setzen wir zum wohle der
familien zum wohle der kinder in unserem
land hat
dorothee bär die stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der unionsfraktion
und wer von wem abgeschrieben hat bei
den gesetzentwürfen ja dazu wird
vielleicht noch die eine oder andere
stellungnahme geben der gesetzentwurf
der unionsfraktion ist wohl schon im
ausschuss für erledigt erklärt worden
man hat sich da abgestimmt zwischen der
andere koalition und dann wird das wohl
nachher zustimmung geben jetzt hören wir
für die spd übrig liebe kollegen
kolleginnen sehr geehrte frau minister
innen es ist bemerkenswert dass wir in
dieser noch sehr jungen wahlperiode
bereits zum dritten mal in vier wochen
über die finanzierung des ganztags
ausbaus der grundschulkinder sprechen
aber das bildungs- und
familienpolitikerin ist mir das
natürlich mehr als recht besonders wenn
es vorangeht heute machen wir mit dem
breit signalisierten zustimmungen der
fraktionen den weg frei für längere
fristen und das ist der unterschied zu
ihrem antrag für kollegin bern nämlich
auch weniger bürokratie beim abruf der
mittel für den ganztags ausbauen
gut das ist gut und richtig ist jetzt
gleich zu beginn diese wahlperiode das
signal dass es uns ernst ist mit guter
bildung und echten chancen für alle
kinder die förderung von kindern im
ganztag ist nach dem digital praktischen
ein weiteres projekt bei dem sich die
neue kooperation von bund und ländern im
bildungsbereich bewerben kann denn wo
große nationale anstrengungen
erforderlich sind brauchen wir ein
kooperations gebot kein
kooperationsverbot
wo gibt es die ganztags förderung ganz
praktisch mit leben zu füllen vor ort
mit kindgerechten räumen und
bewegungsmöglichkeiten mit
qualifiziertem und motiviertem
fachpersonal und vor allem mit klugen
konzepten und angeboten die schulische
förderung muss sich sportliche bildung
aber auch spiel spaß und soziales
miteinander unter einen hut bringen wir
als bund stellen erst einmal nur nur in
anführungszeichen das geld zur verfügung
ein durchaus wichtiger aspekt denn ohne
verlässliche finanzierungszusagen können
die kommunen nicht planen und sich nicht
an die arbeit machen dennoch die
eigentliche anstrengung folgt noch und
wird uns auf allen ebenen bund länder
und kommunen noch weiter beschäftigen
noch dringlicher als tv vorhaben und
noch wesentlich langsamer zu bewältigen
ist der fachkräftemangel in der
tierischen berufen und ich bin sehr froh
dass wir uns im koalitionsvertrag der
regierungsparteien darauf verständigt
haben mit hoher priorität mit den
ländern und allen relevanten akteuren
eine gesamtstrategie zu entwickeln um
den fachkräftebedarf für
erziehungsberufe zu sichern
hier liegt auch am herzen keine
unerwünschten konkurrenzen aufzubauen
neben kita und grundschule braucht auch
die erziehungshilfe ganz dringend mehr
qualifiziertes personal
diese sorge und jugendämter und freie
träger darum ist es nötig sehr schnell
voranzukommen mit einem
bundeseinheitlichen rahmen für eine
vergütet und attraktive ausbildung und
auch mehr studienplätze zu schaffen für
soziale arbeit und pädagogik
weiterbildungen zweite ausbildungen und
solide nach qualifizierungen für
quereinsteiger müssen das angebot
abrunden die investitionen in unsere
kinder dulden keinen aufschub denn
bildung und gutes aufwachsen hat ein
enges zeitfenster in der pandemie ist
uns das wieder sehr plastisch klar
geworden als lehrerin habe ich immer
wieder sehr eindrücklich erlebt wie
schwierig es ist auch größere lernen
rückstände im laufenden schulbetrieb
auch wieder aufzuholen und ähnliches
gilt auch für soziale lernen erfahrungen
darum haben wir heute zu fristen
verlängert um auf stoff mangel und
fehlende planungskapazitäten zu
reagieren aber wir dürfen uns trotzdem
keine zeit lassen auch die qualitative
ausgestaltung und weiterentwicklung der
ganztagsangebote wollen wir in dieser
wahlperiode begleiten und fördern denn
die qualität entscheidet darüber ob
kinder nur verwahrt oder umfassend
gefördert werden
und nur die förderung bietet wirkliche
bildungschancen zur qualität gehört auch
schulen zu öffnen erfahrungsräume
zweiten mit externen partnern
zusammenzuarbeiten und eine aktive
partnerschaft von schule und jugendhilfe
umzusetzen damit meine ich auch aber
keineswegs nur die schulsozialarbeit die
seit dem sommer letztendlich im achter
sozialgesetzbuch verankert ist und auch
hier gibt es ein projekt für diese
wahlperiode
die koalitionsfraktionen haben
beschlossen an schulen in sozialen
brennpunkten
dauerhaft schulische sozialarbeit zu
fördern
darüber hinaus wünsche ich mir viele
kooperationen mit der offenen
jugendarbeit ein ungewohntes terrain für
die schulen aber eine bereicherung für
die kinder im sinne eines ganzheitlichen
bildungsansatz es heute im
heute sollten wir erst einmal dafür dass
die mittel für den ganztag bei den
ländern und kommunen wirklich abgerufen
werden können und ein kleines puzzleteil
ist es auf dem weg zur besseren bildung
und familienfreundlichen strukturen in
deutschland daran vielen dank für die
zustimmung und unterstützung
dann heben
ulrike bahr war das aus der spd-fraktion
in der zweiten und dritten beratung zu
ganztags finanzierungsgesetzes geht
insbesondere darum dass
finanzierungshilfen des bundes an die
länder zum ausbau von ganztags
betreuungsmöglichkeiten verlängert
werden und jetzt spricht in dieser
debatte martin reichert für die afg
fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren schon die
letzte debatte hat gezeigt dass die
fristverlängerung des ganztags
finanzierungsgesetzes im grunde eine
scheindebatte zwischen alter und neuer
regierung ist es geht darum wer was
vergessen hat und das hat man sich auch
heute hier wieder vorgeworfen sie reden
über ganztagsbetreuung während sich
schüler in ganz deutschland ihr recht
auf bildung mit tests und impfungen er
kaufen sollen sie reden von
ganztagsbetreuung und meinen eigentlich
die schnellstmögliche mobilmachung von
eltern für den arbeitsmarkt
wir als dfb wollen selbstbestimmte
wahlfreiheit der eltern zwischen
elterlicher und fremdbetreuung und
können uns von daher in dieser frage nur
enthalten
sie reden meine damen und herren von
ganztagsbetreuung deren die fdp
bildungsministerin sagt impfung von
schulkindern sei ein wichtiger beitrag
um präsenzunterricht versichern die fdp
zusammen mit ihnen allen hier von den
anderen fraktionen nehmen sich die
freiheit heraus eltern zu drangsalieren
mit impfung oder schulschließung mit
impfungen oder ausschluss von sozialer
teilhabe
jetzt sollen schon die fünfjährigen die
ärmel hochkrempeln um sich damit bildung
und letztlich dann auch die von ihnen
hier versprochene teilhabe zu sichern
dazu sagen wir eindeutig nein hände weg
von unseren kindern
wer ständig schwäbelnde minister
lauterbach nötigt kinder und eltern zu
einer impfung mit aussagen die keine
fakten check standhalten liebe eltern
können eltern eigentlich eine minister
vertrauen der sich in der vergangenheit
öfter gehört hat als er seine socken
wechselt meine damen und herren
können eltern politikern vertrauen die
mit kalter berechnungen kindern einreden
dass sie eine gefahr sind liebe eltern
vertrauen sie nicht denen denen das wohl
unserer kinder weniger wert ist und um
das sie sich weniger scheren als um ihre
ablehnung der impfpflicht von gestern
meine damen und herren
und in dieser ganzen frage geht es auch
weiter die stiko gibt gibt eine
empfehlung für vor erkrankte kinder von
fünf bis elf jahren und deren impfung
also keine allgemeine empfehlung für
diese altersgruppe das paul ehrlich
institut weist fünf kinder aus dem
zusammenhang mit der impfung gestorben
sind und viele ärzte weisen diese als
medizinisch nicht ausreichend zurück
trotz all dieser bedenken sollen jetzt
das hat sehr viel damit zu tun sollen
jetzt kinder in zoos von mobilen impf
teams geimpft werden meine damen und
herren sie reden von ganztagsbetreuung
aber sie machen das eine sie würdigen
kinder seit monaten zur verfügungsmasse
ihrer politik herab
die familienministerin spiegel wilden im
vw mit der impfung ab fünf jahren die
pandemie in die knie zwingen meine damen
und herren allein für diese unsinnige
aussage müssten sie eigentlich ihren
stuhl wieder räumen
hören sie endlich auf die kinder und die
eltern zu instrumentalisieren stellen
sie wirkliche normalität in der
betreuung von kindern und in der bildung
wieder her die roten linien sind
überschritten das hat ihr kanzler
bereits gesagt beenden sie endlich die
unsinnigen corona maßnahmen für kinder
vielen dank
und damit ihr keine missverständnisse
aufkommen dieser tagesordnungspunkt der
gerade diskutiert wird in dem geht es um
die verlängerung des
investitionsprogramms für die
ganztagsbetreuung da gibt es ja ein
gesetz und ab
von apa das hat sich 21 wird ein
rechtsanspruch auf ganztagsbetreuung für
alle kinder im grundschulalter ab dem
ersten august 20 26 stufenweise
eingeführt jetzt die zweite ministerin
in dieser debatte bettina stark
watzinger
aus der fdp bundesministerin für bildung
und forschung
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen herr
abgeordneter reichhaltig muss auf ihre
unhaltbaren aussagen gar nicht eingehen
aber klar impfen ist der weg aus der
krise
das angebot an die kinder ist eine
chance das spiel - und stattdessen fand
vermutlich schwächsten in unserer
gesellschaft überhaupt eine chance haben
wir sprechen heute vordergründige eine
fristverlängerung aber dahinter steht
vielmehr wir wissen doch heute das die
grundlage für die bildungswege in der
frühen kindheit gelegt werden und wenn
wir heute darüber sprechen dass der
ganztag kommt züge kommt das versprechen
auf den ganztag dann ist das auch das
angebot an chancen an chancen im
bildungsweg das geht uns alle an
deswegen ist es gut das bild geschossen
und letzteres ist nicht sinnvoll da sind
wir uns einig wer heute ein handwerker
buchen möchte der weiß wie das ist und
deswegen ist es gut dass wir es machen
und liebe frau bär ich freue mich auf
die zusammenarbeit und ich bin mir
sicher die wird gut sein aber ist ein
kluger hesse hat gesagt denken muss man
selber und das kann ich ihnen
versprechen können wir als regierung und
deswegen ist unser gesetzentwurf
besser als das was sie als antrag
eingebracht so dass wir das
unkompliziert machen das ist ein teil
dessen was wir kooperations gebot nennen
es muss uns um die sache gehen jafran
konjunkturpaket mittel aber die länder
brauchen mehr zeit da geht es jetzt
nicht um alte politische muster wir
ändern zügig das gesetz ein jahr länger
zeit die länder kommen leichter an die
mittel die bonus mittel sollen in den
basis top fließen anteil für jedes land
ergibt sich aus dem königsteiner
schlüssel das ist das was wir brauchen
kooperation hand in hand von bund
ländern und kommunen
reibungslos zielorientiert und immer mit
dem blick was den bürgerinnen und bürger
in unserem land wirklich nicht daran
brauchen wir
die prägung in unserem land voranbringen
wollen denn auch darin sind wir uns
einig die bildung in unserem land ist
nicht auf dem niveau das wir uns für ein
industrie und eine kulturnation wie wir
sind uns wünschen jeder fünfte
jugendliche kann nicht gut lesen schon
in der grundschule hartes lernen dort
wirklich die kinder die grundkompetenzen
lesen und schreiben nein sagt uns die
wissenschaft zu viele lernen ist nicht
ausreichend da müssen wir ran mit mehr
engagement engagement breiterem
engagement und vor allen dingen mit viel
mehr mut meine damen und herren
und das ziel die welt beste bildung für
alle unabhängig von wohnort von der
herkunft und darf man ob eltern
unterstützen oder nicht der bund steht
bereit wir wollen keine zentrale
bildungspolitik im sinne von ersetzen
der bund leistet ein und ob engagement
für eine und topbildung meine damen und
herren und dazu gehört dass wir den
schulen auch mehr freiraum lassen
schulen die viel mehr selbst bestimmen
sie wissen was ihre schülerinnen und
schüler brauchen das ist der weg zu mehr
qualität der rechtsanspruch kommt und da
muss auch das angebot stimmen da geht es
nicht um quantität sondern da geht es
auch um qualität nur so nutzen wir die
chance des ganztags besseres lesen
lernen mit sport und soziales lernen das
ist der weg in die bildungsrepublik
das beste weg den
911er neuen bundesregierung mehr
qualität in der bildung zu sichern ich
will dazu so schnell wie möglich mit den
ländern ins gespräch kommen mehr zeit
und geld in bildung
investieren das heißt gut investieren
jedes kind dass wir so mitnehmen ist ein
gewinn meine damen und herren
und deshalb
deshalb ist klar wenn der bund extra
geld gibt dann muss auch extra qualität
ankommen das müssen wir möglich machen
dafür treten wir als regierung dafür
trete ich als ministerin an meine damen
und herren vielen dank
[Applaus]
für die fraktion die linke hat nun die
kollegin nicole gohlke dass
nicole gohlke ist eine der
stellvertretenden fraktionsvorsitzenden
gehen der linksfraktion
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen jetzt bringen wir also heute
auf den weg dass die mittel für den
beschleunigten ausbau des ganztags nicht
nur bis ende diesen jahres sondern bis
ende nächsten jahres abgerufen werden
können das ist eigentlich eine
selbstverständlichkeit es schafft
planungssicherheit für die länder
kommunen und träger und deswegen stimmt
die linke diesen gesetzentwurf der ampel
auch zu aber ich muss schon sagen ich
muss schon sagen kolleginnen und
kollegen diese letzten drei debatten zu
diesem thema mit heute sind es ja sogar
glaube ich vier haben schon auch so ein
bisschen ein geschmäckle wie man so
schön sagt die rednerinnen und redner
der ampel feiern sich hier für diese
selbstverständlichkeit ab und man kann
wirklich nur hoffen dass die union
irgendwann mal ihre phantomschmerzen
überwinden wird nicht mehr zu regieren
das ist auf jeden fall noch ein bisschen
ein problem jetzt kolleginnen und
kollegen jetzt muss es aber darum gehen
den rechtsanspruch für auf
ganztagsbetreuung für grundschulkinder
auch realität werden zu lassen ihn auch
umzusetzen jetzt muss es um die fragen
gehen wie der enorme fachkräftemangel im
bildungsbereich beseitigt werden kann
denn ohne mehr personal ohne mehr
pädagogisches personal und fachkräfte
ohne mehr
schulsozialarbeiterinnen und
schulsozialarbeiter wird ein ganztag ja
gar nicht möglich sein und es muss jetzt
dringend und qualitätsstandards gehen
darum wie wir zu einem guten ganztag
kommen dass wir nämlich wollen ist ein
ganztag wo die kinder gerne hingehen
weil es mehr ist als die verlängerung
von leistungsdruck und stress in den
nachmittag hinein sondern wo ein
angemessener betreuungsschlüssel und
kleine gruppen endlich mit dabei helfen
die soziale spaltung in diesem land zu
beenden das sind jetzt die themen die an
stehen kolleginnen und kollegen lassen
sie uns nicht weiter kostbare zeit
verplempern machen sie einen aufschlag
zur entwicklung verbindlicher
qualitätsstandards legen sie eine
zeitplan vor spannen sie die
kultusminister in den konferenz die
jugend und familienministerin konferenz
die fachverbände mit ein und dann lassen
sie uns loslegen wir arbeiten gerne
daran mit vielen dank
sagt nicole boote die steine der
stellvertretenden vorsitzenden der
linksfraktion
und ihr wird jetzt folgen am rednerpult
maria lisa maria potthoff maja dieser
verlassen aus der spd-fraktion mitglied
im ausschuss für bildung forschung und
technikfolgenabschätzung
und es geht nach wie vor in den ausbau
der ganztagsbetreuung für
grundschulkinder
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren in meiner rede vor ein
paar wochen habe ich übrigens auch wie
viele kolleginnen und kollegen der jetzt
neuen ampel koalition versprochen dass
wir uns als neue regierung zeitnah um
die fristverlängerung für den abruf der
beschleunigungs mittel für den ganztags
aufbau kümmern werden liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen wissen so was unsere
botschaft damals an schulträger an
familien an unsere kommunale familie
deutlich wir lassen euch nicht allein
und
vier wochen später liegt bereits das
gesetz von spd von bündnis 90 die grünen
und der fdp vor und heute befinden wir
uns jetzt in der abschließenden lesung
ein blick auf die überschrift unseres
koalitionspartners
und damit dass das motto der ampel
koalition deutlich und klar gesagt getan
wir erkennen die probleme und kümmern
uns zeitnah um deren lösung darauf
können sich die familien die bürgerinnen
und bürger und unserem land verlassen
und vielleicht auch selber april sind
nicht nur unsere familien können sich
auf uns auf die ampel verlassen auch die
bürgermeisterinnen und bürgermeister die
kommunalpolitik und kommunalpolitiker im
grunde ist zu den kriterien der fristen
verlängerung zum gesetzentwurf schon
alles gesagt worden meine liebe kollegin
ulrike bahr und auch unsere beiden neuen
ministerin herzlich willkommen hier
unsere bildungs und familienpolitik
familien haben das schon sehr
detailliert ausgeführt ich möchte daher
den fokus setzen auf das was wir uns in
der ampelkoalition im bereich ganztag in
den nächsten vier jahren vorgenommen
haben
der koalitionsvertrag ist überschrieben
mit mehr fortschritt wagen und als
lehrerin die viele jahre auch selber
unterrichtet hat weiß ich wie wichtig
eine gute bildung ist echter fortschritt
klappt nämlich nur mit einer guten
bildung die eltern unabhängig ist und
von der herkunft der eltern entkoppelt
wird
das große versprechen der deutschen
sozialdemokratie daran arbeiten wir mit
unseren partnern schon seit vielen
vielen jahrzehnten wir sind noch nicht
am ziel aber ich glaube wir werden es
erreichen das ist unsere große hoffnung
für unsere kinder die unsere zukunft
sind und am ende des tages geht es nicht
nur um den ganztag in der grundschule es
geht auch um eine bildungschance so von
der kita über die schule des hin zum
meister oder zum master
und der ganztag spielt dort eine
schlüsselrolle frau stark watzinger hat
es eben auch schon ausgeführt und am
ende müssen wir uns tatsächlich mit zwei
punkten noch mal verstärkt beschäftigen
das eine ist die frage der qualität wie
wir sie definieren dieser qualität im
ganztag eigentlich aussehen und mit der
frage wie wir den fachkräftemangel lösen
werden
wissen sie wenn man als lehrkraft in
einer klasse steht und mitbekommt wie
viel arbeit das ist wie man rödl muss 20
oder sogar 30 kinder und jugendlichen
mit unterschiedlicher ausbildung mit
unterschiedlichen perspektiven mit einem
unterschiedlichen rucksack mit dem man
dort ankommt wenn man die mitnehmen das
ist ganz ganz viel arbeit und umso
kleiner die kinder sind umso aufwendiger
ist das ganze von daher ist das eine
aufgabe die wir schultern müssen wir der
bund in zusammenarbeit mit unseren
ländern mit unseren kommunen ganztag ist
eine gemeinschaftsaufgabe liebe
kolleginnen kollegen
dürfen die lehrkräfte und pädagogische
mitarbeiterin mitarbeiter eben aber auch
alle anderen die in schule und kita
arbeiten an dieser stelle nicht alleine
lassen und meine botschaft als spd
bundestagsabgeordnete ist wir die ampel
lassen sie und lassen euch an dieser
stelle nicht alleine und heute ist der
erste beweis dafür dass wir unseren
worten die wir uns in den
koalitionsvertrag hineingeschrieben
haben auch taten folgen lassen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich freue mich
auf die nächsten vier jahre gemeinsam
mit den kolleginnen und kollegen von den
grünen und fdp mit unseren glaube ich
sehr tollen ministerin ich freue mich
schon auf die zusammenarbeit dieses
thema weiter zu betreuen in diesem sinne
ihnen allen ein frohes weihnachtsfest
maria lisa feller sommer nur noch mit
ein klein wenig überschwang in richtung
der neuen ampel koalitionen sie war die
vorletzte rednerin in dieser beratung
letzter redner wird andré berghegger
sein der aus der unions fraktion kommt
und
diese aussprache das beschließen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren
lassen sie mich zum schluss der debatte
noch einige gedanken an sie richten aus
sicht der kommunen ich würde mal sagen
konstruktive opposition zahlt sich aus
das sieht man an diesem beispiel
deswegen vielen dank an
vielen dank an die kolleginnen und
kollegen aus meiner fraktion die sich
immer wieder um dieses thema gekümmert
haben aber ehrlicherweise wir stimmen am
ende zu das hat meine kollegin wir haben
anfang gesagt aber etwas wasser muss
sich in den wein doch gießen sehen sie
es als anregungen für zukünftige
projekte worum geht es eigentlich wir
haben den anspruch auf ganztagsbetreuung
für die grundschulkinder und dieser
erfordert natürlich bautechnisch eine
riesen kraftanstrengung das haben wir
gehört keine zeit ist zu verlieren denn
es fehlen rund 800.000 zusätzliche
plätze um diesen anspruch ab 226
aufsteigend umzusetzen der bund
unterstützt diese baumaßnahmen
holzschnittartig mit dreieinhalb
milliarden euro und ein teil dieser
mittel
750 millionen werden für den
beschleunigten ausbau vorgesehen der
begriff gibt es vor die mittel sollen
schnell umgesetzt werden damit schnell
gebaut werden kann aber die frist für
den mittelabruf dieser mittel durch die
kommunen die frist solche und dieses
jahr enden und das ist natürlich viel zu
schnell für die kommunen und bedeutet
große probleme und darauf reagieren wir
jetzt aber ehrlicherweise die
vorliegenden gesetzes änderungen hätten
viel schneller kommen können und konnten
kommen müssen denn sie sind wir reden
nicht von einer woche denn sie sind
dringend notwendig sie alle wissen die
kommunen sind nicht originär zuständig
für die ganztagsbetreuung im
grundschulalter
der bund wenn er fördert das macht ja
gerne muss aber praktikable regelungen
treffen und da gibt es luft nach oben
für die zukunft die kommunen brauchen
planungssicherheit beim ausbau keine
unsicherheit es geht doch wer vor ort
ist werde den kontakt zu den kommunen
hat es geht um große bausumme liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von der ampel
mit etwas mehr mut mit etwas mehr
entscheidungsfreude wäre das thema schon
längst entschieden und das haben sie
leider versäumt
wir hatten
wir hatten bereits vor wochen einen
entsprechenden antrag gestellt den haben
sie geparkt und damit wertvolle zeit
verstreichen lassen ehrlicherweise bis
zum letzten sitzungstages bis zum
letzten sitzungstag dieses jahres und
das ist recht knapp und diesen
zeitverlust den können die kommunen
eigentlich nicht so hinnehmen und das
müssen sie sich vorhalten lassen wenn
wir wenn wir nicht immer wieder druck
gemacht hätten würden sie würden sie im
zweifel wir verlassen uns doch auf die
gesetzesbeschlüsse und nicht auf
ankündigungen das müssen sie auch immer
berücksichtigen
sie kennen ich komme ja noch dazu sie
kennen doch die angespannte situation im
bausektor bei den handwerkern das führt
zu verzögerungen es wäre wichtig gewesen
den frist zum abruf dieser besonderen
mittel viel schneller um ein jahr auf
das ende 2022 zu verlängern die kommunen
müssen noch die chance haben diese
mittel auch abzurufen
so stark watzinger ich höre diese großen
linien gerne und dafür schätze ich sie
auch das unterstreiche ich auch das
finde ich auch richtig aber wir müssen
noch in zukunft auf praxisgerechte
regelung warten und wir wissen doch dass
mit dem zögern dem ganztags ausbau
ehrlicherweise zum teil ein bärendienst
erbracht worden ist wir haben es zu
vertreten wenn einzelne baumaßnahmen
wegen der unsicherheit verschoben worden
sind und teilweise sogar weniger plätze
vorhanden sind als zuvor weil wir wissen
doch auch in der praxis manchmal werden
baukörper abgerissen um praxisgerecht um
neue modern im größer zu bauen und wenn
eine unsicherheit vorherrscht dann
stellt man eben als bürgermeisterin
oberbürgermeister eine solche maßnahme
ein jetzt holen wir das nach es ist aber
eine anregung für die zukunft
und ihre und ihre begründung
ihr gesetzesentwurf sei ja weitergehen
da weil er die technisch komplizierten
boos und basis mittel zusammenführt
ehrlicherweise überzeugt mich das nicht
ganz wir hätten ohne probleme in unserem
gesetzesentwurf eine änderung aufnehmen
können wir hätten schon bereits im
sommer einen vorschlag gemacht gemacht
das wurde auch schon angesprochen der
damalige finanzminister hat das nicht
akzeptiert das finde ich schade und
fahrlässig und sie schreiben sich doch
auch die fahnen enger mit den kommunen
zusammenzuarbeiten und deswegen mache
ich mir sorgen für die zukunft ich würde
mir wünschen verlässlichkeit gegen
gegenüber den kommunen die sieht aus
meiner sicht anders aus handeln sie
bitte schneller und pragmatischer lassen
sie ihren worten auch taten folgen die
kommunen müssen wir nicht verunsichern
lieber matthias seestern pauly sondern
wir sollten ihnen vertrauen und sie
stärken vielen dank fürs freundlichen zu
lernen
ich schließe die aussprache wir kommen
zur abstimmung über den von den
fraktionen der spd bündnis 90/die grünen
und fdp
eingebrachten gesetzentwurf zur änderung
des ganztags finanzierungsgesetzes und
des ganztags finanzhilfe gesetzes der
hauptausschuss empfiehlt unter buchstabe
aus einer beschlussempfehlung auf
drucksache
259 den gesetzentwurf der fraktionen der
spd bündnis 90/die grünen und fdp auf
drucksache
190 anzugehen ich bitte diejenigen die
dem gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen um
das handzeichen
danke bestimmt dagegen wer enthält sich
dann können der gesetzentwurf ist mit
den stimmen der koalitionsfraktionen
der fraktion die linke der fraktion der
cdu/csu bei enthaltung der fdp fraktion
angenommen dritte beratung und
schlussabstimmung ich bitte diejenigen
die dem gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen
sich zu erheben
bestimmt dagegen
niemand er enthält sich
danke der gesetzentwurf ist bei
enthaltung der fdp fraktion mit den
stimmen der übrigen fraktionen des
hauses angenommen
unter buchstabe b sah in der
beschlussempfehlung empfiehlt der
hauptausschuss den von der fraktion der
cdu/csu eingebrachten gesetzentwurf zur
fristverlängerung für den beschleunigten
infrastrukturausbau in der
ganztagsbetreuung für grundschulkinder
auf drucksache 83 für erledigt zu
erklären wer stimmt für diese
beschlussempfehlung
dank bestimmter gegenwehr enthält sich
die beschlussempfehlung ist einstimmig
angenommen
tagesordnungspunkt 6 b wir setzen die
abstimmung zu der beschlussempfehlung
des hauptausschusses auf drucksache
259 wort der ausschuss empfiehlt unter
buchstabe c seiner beschlussempfehlung
den antrag der fraktionen der cdu/csu
auf drucksache 29 mit dem titel
planungssicherheit für familien und
kommunen frist für den beschleunigten
infrastrukturausbau in der
ganztagsbetreuung verlängern für
erledigt zu erklären wer stimmt führt
diese beschlussempfehlung
danke wer stimmt dagegen enthält sich
die beschlussempfehlung ist einstimmig
angenommen